any advice to other filmmakers on taking
time out to make a big decision like
that just like basic things you talked
about you know you would find
distractions before go for a walk drink
some water check emails yeah revisit
revisit your cut because when you're
sitting with a cut every day over and
over and over and over again your
perspective is like clouded with the
reality of the technical issues or the
sound problems or you know a cut that
you're like oh my god this cut works
because you're in it so much and then
you step away and you step away for a
couple of days like there was a date
yeah i took some breaks i took a couple
days off did something else came back to
it and i rewatched it you know sometimes
I come back and I wouldn't just start
editing again I'd take back and I
watched the 80 minutes that I'd had so
far to see the flow because this one
thing to see like oh this scene works
but not against this others you know not
against what its next to and some things
are redundant so like I remember our
film had several different versions of
experiencing the temple and I think like
you don't need to see it you know
several times but a couple perspectives
of somethings interesting so to see a
contrast is interesting but now you know
to see something over and over and over
is maybe less interesting so you try to
see like from an audience perspective
like what's interesting is this still
engaging is this still something that
like and I am I properly getting the
experience over to someone who might
watch it did you have in mind the
footage that you were going to use to
replace was their stuff that was like oh
that's so close to making it but no
we're going to get rid of it and then
once you had to take this out you said I
know exactly what it is I'm going to put
in well yeah I mean once I had the
decided to read it the foam I knew
exactly what I was going to do and lucky
enough the way it worked is because
there were so many people involved in
the project that had different
experiences out there there was a whole
experience that actually wasn't included
in in one version of it and so I ended
up being able to
what's awesome about adobe premiere is
you just tag all your clips with
different colors different label colors
and so I had a different color for every
person that was involved in project
think eight or nine different colors and
so basically I pulled in all the
different colors sorted everything and
basically the film as you see it now has
has five different people's experiences
and I was able to add back in an
experience that was originally in one of
the rough cuts and so it makes it makes
an amazing balance now where you have
the different different perspectives
you